[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Mittag erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen Minecraft
Welt über meine lieben Freunde könnt ihr
vielleicht schon ansehen ich bin happy
denn es hat aufgehört zu regnen also an
alle unter euch die vielleicht gerade
binsch watching machen oder wie hat heiß
also wenn man sich dieses komplette
Projekt hier nacheinander anguckt dann
wisst ihr wahrscheinlich dass in der
letzten Episode ist noch komplett
geregnet hat wir können dich erstmal
ganz kurz hier so ein bisschen wieder
aufpäppeln es hat in der letzten Episode
ordentlich geschüttet hier in der Welt
und jetzt ist es auf jeden Fall wieder
ziemlich aufgehaltert dich hier vorne
können wir auch mal eben wieder ein
bisschen reparieren so ich möchte mal
ganz kurz eben zu unserem Kollegen gehen
der uns die Sachen ja verkaufen wollte
also die enderperlen der hat nämlich
immer noch keine
Blödmann dann haben wir hier ehrlich
gesagt auf der Insel auch nichts mehr zu
suchen wir müssen nämlich eh zurück zu
meinem Dorf bzw ich habe kein eigenes
Dorf hier in Minecraft aber ich habe
Hunger
apropos Hunger übrigens meine lieben
Freunde mir wurde zahlreiche in die
Kommentare geschrieben weil ich ja
wieder ziemlich lost unterwegs war und
dachte das Ofenkartoffeln das beste
Essen in Minecraft sind äh nee ist es
irgendwie komischerweise nicht sondern
goldene Karotten wurde mir geschrieben
also danke danke danke dafür den Hinweis
wahrscheinlich ja
der Hinweis Dankeschön da auf jeden Fall
für eure Hilfe in den Kommentaren ich
werde auf jeden Fall gleich mein
restliches Knochenmehl nehmen und unten
alle Kartoffeln und Weizen Sachen und
keine Ahnung was ich noch in meiner
unterirdischen Farm angebaut habe das
werde ich auf jeden Fall alles abreißen
oder abbauen ab Farmen keine Ahnung was
der richtige Begriff in der
Landwirtschaft ist allerdings wenn ich
alles zu Kleister mit Karotten denn ich
habe so unmenschlich viel Gold noch dass
ich das alles zu Gold Karotten machen
kann und das wird fürs Ende und für
meinen Magen im Ende eine extrem große
Bereicherung sein allerdings meine
lieben Freunde wollten wir noch mehr in
die Kommentare geschrieben denn mir
wurde auch unter die Arme gegriffen beim
Thema Phantome ihr wisst ja dass ich
immer noch auf die Phantome warte ich
war mittlerweile seit fünf Nächten oder
so nicht schlafen in Minecraft und äh
erstmal falls ihr vielleicht gerade neu
einsteigt ich glaube nicht dass
irgendwer jetzt gerade in Folge keine
Ahnung wo wir sind 96 glaube ich
mittlerweile schon äh dass da irgendwer
neu dazu kommt bei dem Projekt aber ich
warte immer noch auf Phantom und wir
brauchen Phantome in dieser Welt hier
bzw das was die Phantome droppen rauchen
wird es Tom heute und die müssen wir in
unserem braustand zu einem trank des
sanften falls verzaubern ich kenne mich
damit selber noch nicht so richtig aus
allerdings ist der Trank des sanften
falls von ungeheuriger Wichtigkeit für
unsere endmissionen was hat schön hier
vorne mit dem Leuchtturm da hinten mit
dem Ballon rechts daneben äh wir
brauchen auf jeden Fall diesen sanften
Fall trank definitiv fürs Ende weil wir
da die ganze Zeit von dem Enderdrachen
hoch und runter geschleudert werden
allerdings wollte ich ja gerade sagen
dass mir das mit den Phantom erklärt
wurde und zwar ist es nicht so dass man
drei Nächte am Stück wach bleiben muss
und dann zack sind die Phantome da nee
die Wahrscheinlichkeit steigert sich
einfach nur also wenn ich drei Nächte am
Stück wach bin ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwie ein Viertel
wenn ich dann vier Nächte am Stück wach
bin ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit 25 also
das ist dann
eine geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit ich
Mathegenie das heißt allerdings dass wir
auf jeden Fall weiterhin nicht schlafen
können Beziehungen
Erfahrung war das noch von der Spinne
naja wir ähm
sterblich mit
relativ lang nicht mehr gegengehauen ich
habe auch extrem lange nicht mehr gegen
den sitzbaum gehauen der erzählt uns ja
dann immer einen Witz der einzige Witz
mit deinen Kampf gegen den Enderdrachen
sein
da muss ich die widersprechen der mir
wurde auch unten in die Kommentare
geschrieben dass ich jetzt bitte endlich
mal meine Rüstung hier reparieren soll
ich weiß nicht ob
oh das ist nicht dein Ernst oder
ach chillig jetzt ist es sogar einen
Gewitter
okay das heißt allerdings meine lieben
Freunde das jetzt auch wieder Monster
spawnen können von daher nutze ich die
Zeit wo es jetzt gerade gewittert
einfach mal ganz kurz um euch erstmal
ganz kurz zu sagen dass ich meine
Rüstung auf jeden Fall heute reparieren
werde das müssen auf jeden Fall machen
allerdings euch jetzt eine ganz große
Tablet wie ich meine Sachen hier
sortiert
so meine lieben Freunde ich habe jetzt
gerade mal schnell meine Sachen sortiert
das war waren jetzt einfach nur
anderthalb Minuten hat sich die Therme
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht gelohnt
allerdings seht ihr schon unten dass ich
zwei Karotten leider nur habe und die
muss ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen mit
Knochenmehl befeuern da wurde mir auch
unten in die Kommentare geschrieben
irgendwann mal letztens ich werde den
Kommentar nicht mehr finden deswegen
sorry dass ich jetzt nicht einblenden
konnte allerdings hat es eh nicht
funktioniert denn ähm mir wurde
geschrieben Luca wenn Du beispielsweise
Weizen anpflanzt kannst du einfach mit
Rechtsklick äh dir nur das Weizen holen
und nicht die Samen die Samen bleiben
dann stehen das ist irgendwie da hätte
wohl Zeit gespart und so allerdings
funktioniert das nicht in der Version
und der ich gerade spiele nämlich in der
Java Version und nicht irgendwie in der
Bedrock Version oder keine Ahnung wo das
ganze funktioniert das sind ja immer
diese lifehacks so ein bisschen bei mir
funktioniert das Ganze auf jeden Fall
leider nicht allerdings
mehr kriege ich gerade nicht hin am
liebsten würde ich euch jetzt gerade
Teil mit einblenden wie ich jetzt zwei
Stunden vorstellen dann klappt das alles
oder
wir holen uns einfach Knochenmehl
dadurch dass wir jetzt ein paar Skelette
Boxen gehen zunächst müssen uns
allerdings hier einen kohleblock
rausnehmen denn ich habe ja hier einige
Kartoffeln noch am Start und die wollte
ich auf jeden Fall in den Ofen packen
zuvor bekommt ihr beiden allerdings
einfache Stück Fleisch und jetzt
sprinten wir mal ganz schnell
irgendwas explodiert
eine Hexe getötet sonst wäre hier kein
Zucker rausgekommen aber gut wir
sprinten auf jeden Fall mal ganz fix
hier vorne zu unserem Ofen und packen
ich schau die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen
am Himmel weil ich hoffe dass
irgendwelche Phantome kommen packe hier
einen kohleblock rein und die Kartoffel
ich weiß jetzt nicht mir wurde auch
irgendwas in die Kommentare geschrieben
von wegen luca du musst unter freiem
Himmel sein damit die Phantome spawnen
das wage ich zu bezweifeln ob ich jetzt
Schlafmangel drin oder draußen habe es
ja auch relativ unglaublich das
verrottete Fleisch packe ich noch mal
eben kurz in die Kiste mit den Sachen
die ich eigentlich nicht essen möchte
bzw auch nicht essen darf weil wir
eigentlich gesagt haben Luca no äh
tierische Sachen essen also keine Tiere
essen so ist richtig allerdings werde
ich mich jetzt mal
schnell weg oh das Bett hier kann ich
auch mal mitnehmen das habe ich da noch
hingesetzt damit ich nicht vergessen
dass ich nicht schlafen gehen darf ich
fahre jetzt auf jeden Fall rüber hier zu
unserer kleinen abbauinsel ich war ja
früher
eingeschlagen
genau hier
[Musik]
war das jetzt ein gutes oder schlechtes
Zeichen oh wir haben da hinten den
Skelett da werde ich direkt mal eben
rüber sprinten wir brauchen nämlich so
viel Knochenmehl wie es geht deswegen
ist es heute eigentlich eine komplette
skelettjagd Folge allerdings wollte ich
das ganze auch nutzen um euch so ein
bisschen den restlichen Folgen Plan zu
erklären da werde ich nämlich zugespamt
in den Kommentaren von wegen wie ist es
denn jetzt genau Luca wirst du irgendwie
in Folge 100 jetzt ins Ende gehen oder
schon eine Folge früher die genau hast
du das geplant ich werde euch das heute
mal so ein bisschen erzählt euch das
ehrlich gesagt jetzt so ein bisschen
erzählen ähm hier kommt wieder so eine
kleine Mini Baby an wir brauchen
eigentlich für das neue
minecraft-projekt da wurde mir auch viel
geschrieben von wegen Luca 1.18 ist
schon draußen also die vorab Version die
will man aber irgendwie nicht spielen
weil da noch voll viele Fehler drin sind
dann wurde mir auch geschrieben Luca
Spiel 1.17 und dann wieder nach
Inversion 1.18 dann bekommst du auch die
krassen Höhlen und so weiter und so fort
also da muss ich mich auch noch mal ein
bisschen genauer informieren die Sache
ist allerdings dass ich
die letzten Folgen dieses Minecraft mit
Luca Projekts wie folgt mir vorstelle
habe ich die Pfeile eingesammelt ja also
wir beschreiben wie nicht beschreiben
wir schreiben gerade Folge 96 heute ist
die vorletzte richtige Folge also die
Folgen der ist nicht um special Sachen
geht Folge 97 also die Folge die jetzt
demnächst kommen ich glaube nicht
übermorgen sondern in vier Tagen ich
weiß es nicht genau ich muss gerade
meinen Ablaufplan nicht so ganz im Kopf
die Sache ist allerdings dass die
nächste auch direkt drei auf einmal die
beiden attackieren sich gegenseitig das
auf jeden Fall sehr gut dann können wir
hier nur auf das hier drauf gehen äh die
Sache ist dass die nächste Folge also
Folge 97
sind schon eine Menge Mops die hier
gerade unterwegs sind ach guck mal die
beiden jagen sich jetzt hier wieder nee
das vielleicht geht auf mich aber hast
auch egal auf jeden Fall ist diese Folge
also Folge 96 noch eine ganz normale
Folge und Folge 97 auch deswegen könnt
ihr mir jetzt bitte bitte bitte gern
unten in die Kommentare schreiben
ihr könnt mir jetzt unten in die
Kommentare schreiben was ich in der
nächsten Episode in Folge 97 als letzte
normale Episode
als letzte normale Episode nochmal
machen soll also soll ich noch mal
irgendwo hinfahren soll ich noch mal
irgendwas erkunden soll ich noch mal
eine Ahnung wohin gehen in der Höhle
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt weil
die nächsten Episoden danach also Folge
100 ja eh schon Action pur wird soll ich
noch mal irgendeine Kleinigkeit bauen
was ich in einer Folge vielleicht
hinkriege habe ich irgendwas vergessen
was ich noch machen wollte unbedingt
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
Kommentare was ich Leute
Alter hier sind aber auch eine Menge
Mops unterwegs
hier
und Leute trymacs hier
um auf den Punkt zu kommen ich bin euch
sehr dankbar für alle Kommentare was ich
in der nächsten Episode Minecraft mit
Luca machen soll denn diese Folge und
wie bereits gesagt folge 97
werden die letzten beiden richtigen
Minecraft folgenden Folge 98 wird eine
komplette vorbereitungsfolge für das
Ende da werde ich Sachen verzaubern ich
werde mich vorbereiten ich werde mir den
Kürbis schnitzen den ich mir dann auf
den Kopf setze und so weiter und so fort
und die Folge 99 also die vorletzte
Folge dieses Projekts generell wird eine
Best of Folge da habe ich alle möglichen
Dateien runtergeladen im Kollegen
geschickt und meinte ey alles was du
witzig findest was du cool findest was
spannend war was interessant war was
dumm war schneit das mal zusammen das
heißt da kommt ein locker 20 Minuten
langes best of als Folge 99 was wir uns
zusammen angucken werden in dieser Welt
und dann ist Folge 99 halt vorbei das
ist quasi das beste auf der werden wir
nichts Produktives machen sondern uns
nur noch mal angucken was wir alles
erlebt haben und Folge 100 wird dann die
endfolge sein also so habe ich mir das
Ganze vorgestellt so habe ich das Ganze
geplant
ich gehe jetzt mal ganz kurz hier rein
und regeneriere erstmal ein bisschen
Leben
während ich aber hier drin stehe kann
ich euch ganz kurz sagen Freunde
passend zur
Mund die ganze Zeit passend zur Folge
100 kommt auch neues merchandise in den
shop.de
dieser los lucross Wetter ist extrem
geil extrem flauschig so ein bisschen
vintage mäßig mit so einem Stück vorne
drauf und so und ein blauer Hoodie kommt
auch noch rein den habe ich jetzt gerade
nicht in den habe ich glaube ich in der
Wäsche weil ich mit nach Köln nehmen
wollte dafür produziere ich gerade die
Videos vor allerdings
seht ihr schon hier wir sind hier im
Dings im Menü da wollte ich euch nämlich
auch ganz kurz was zeigen und zwar habe
ich mir ein neues Texture Pack
runtergeladen ihr seht schon hier das no
pumpkin Blur Texture Pack ihr fragt euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich Luca was macht das
hier habe ich einen geschnitzten Kürbis
und wenn ich mit den auf den Kopf setze
meine Rüstung ist kaputt gegangen
verdammt
muss ich mir eine neue craften na ja ihr
seht schon wenn ich diesen Kürbis auf
dem Kopf habe sieht man fast gar nichts
mehr also eine Hälfte des Bildschirms
locker als du komplett schwarz nur noch
das liegt daran weil ich halt diesen
Kürbis auf dem Kopf habe ist ja logisch
und ich brauche diesen Kürbis auf dem
Kopf weil wenn ich damit einen Enderman
angucke dann greift er mich nicht an die
Sache ist allerdings dass das natürlich
ziemlich stört gerade euch als Zuschauer
man sieht halt fast nichts deswegen habe
ich mir dieses textpack runtergeladen
und wenn ich dieses textpack jetzt
reinpacke dauert erstmal ganz kleinen
Augenblick allerdings sehen wir dann
schon
ich habe einen Kürbis auf dem Kopf aber
sie trotzdem noch alles klar kann man
jetzt sagen das ist natürlich irgendwie
cheaten weil man mehr sieht also für
mich als Spieler ja stimmt auch bin ich
auch dankbar für die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich da wirklich primär
an euch denke so dass ihr das komplette
Erlebnis habt bei Folge 100 und nicht
irgendwie die Hälfte vom Spiel nicht
irgendwie sehen könnt nur weil da der
pumpkin alles verdeckt von daher hoffe
ich mal dass ihr Okay seid mit der
Entscheidung dass ich mir dieses Pack
runtergeladen habe ich glaube es wird
dafür Folge 100 eine deutliche
Bereicherung sein und meine lieben
Freunde was mir auch noch in die
Kommentare geschrieben wurde war
[Musik]
ich habe alles abgearbeitet
das war die produktivste Minecraft mit
Luca Folge aller Zeiten also für mich
ich bin in der Aufnahme bei 24 Minuten
und ich bin durch mit meinem Plan
was ich werde wahrscheinlich extrem
wenig geschnitten haben allerdings es
hat auch aufgehört zu regnen okay
perfekt dann kann ich mich jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz um die Karotten kümmern da
muss man nämlich einfach eine Karotte in
die Mitte legen und drumherum Goldbarren
dann
da muss man nämlich nur eine Karotte in
die Mitte legen und drumherum Gold
Klumpen davon habe ich da sogar noch
eine Menge dann kann man das einfach
damit machen also hier zack hier die
Goldklumpen umrumrum drumherum so dann
können wir uns hier ganz ganz viele
goldene Karotten machen ich weiß nicht
wie viele Goldbarren ich dafür noch
benötige ich mache mir jetzt einfach mal
ein paar ich meine was soll der Geist
das Projekt ist eh schon fast vorbei
also ihr hier alle drumherum zack ihr
hier alle drumherum dann brauche ich
sogar noch ein paar mehr so dass ich das
hier hinkriege aber hiermit sollte es
jetzt glaube ich definitiv reichen zack
zack so jetzt haben wir 25 goldene
Karotten und können damit auf jeden Fall
denke ich dass im Ende ganz gut meistern
das Eisen ist mir gerade hier aus der
Hand gerutscht das Pack ich
ich komme da nicht dran
danke schön das Eisen packe ich auch
noch mal ganz kurz hier rein und werde
jetzt auch mal wieder den Kürbis gegen
meinen diamanthelm tauschen das Bettchen
das nehme ich mir Sicherheit
oh Weg so die spinnenaugen kommen hier
rein der seidene Faden hier vorne die
goldene Karotten ähm pack ich
sicherheitshalber mal hier erstmal die
ganzen unnötigen Sachen reinsprechen
erstmal hier rein weil die ziemlich
wichtig sind jetzt gehen wir noch mal
ganz fix eben zu Balu du kriegst ein
Fleischstück und Balenciaga und wir
haben immer noch kein Phantom und Leute
trymacs hier
ich bin Tom dooline
so der ist tot ich weiß jetzt nicht wo
der andere Creeper ist
beide Creeper tot ich weiß nicht warum
hier so viele Creeper auf dieser Maps in
der es regt mich auch einfach nur noch
auf die Sache ist allerdings meine
lieben Freunde dass ich an der Stelle
die heutige Episode Minecraft mit Luca
jetzt auch beenden würde ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wenn es das getan hat
dann einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da es war krass ich dachte die
Phantome kommen heute weil die
Wahrscheinlichkeit steigt ja allerdings
können wir dann in der nächsten Folge
auch noch nicht schlafen gehen und ich
hoffe dass dann wenigstens ein Phantom
kommt was ich in der nächsten Folge also
der quasi letzten richtigen Folge
Minecraft mit Luca wo ich frei in dem
bin was ich machen kann machen soll
schreibt das gerne unten in die
Kommentare wie bereits gesagt folge 98
wird dann die vorbereitungsfolge fürs
Ende Folge 99 best of in Folge 100 dann
die letzte Folge dieses Projekt ist
Minecraft mit Luca wenn es euch gefallen
hat das gerne einen Daumen hoch unter
dem Video hier dann abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke damit
der neue Videos nicht verpasst und wir
sehen uns dann ein paar Tagen wieder
tschüss
[Musik]